do you think that
if a man should be able to divorce a
woman if let's say like i get married
right and i gain a hundred pounds
and he's no longer attracted to me so
i'm i'm going to look like a different
person
do you think he has a right to divorce
her or vice versa for a man and woman
yeah sure we could do vice versa
like i said there have to have been many
steps
get to that point yeah so a man's just
gonna see his woman getting fat
and just not saying anything and then
wait till she gets to i don't know
however 1000
would you guys have a problem then if a
guy said to you hey like i love you
but you're getting but you're gaining
weight like you've gained 20 pounds the
last six months if you keeps going on to
this route then like i i don't see us
staying together but he's honest with
you he's giving you the opportunity to
lose it so at least he's being honest i
will say this as a man right yeah if a
man
men and women forget men men and women
should find each other attractive they
should find each other attractive
sexually right that's the main key of
keeping the spark in your relationship
and if somebody is um
if if you know your partner is
not finding you attractive because of a
certain thing
it's on you as a man or a woman to say
okay cool
i need to try and get
that person that i've committed to
to find me attractive again men or women
doesn't really matter do you know what i
mean yep
and
that it just made me think about um
how
women will
and maybe some men do it but i haven't
heard that in that type of situation but
women will
do the go to the nine to get a man but
once they've gotten them they'll die
back and they won't they won't do what
they did to get them and the man's like
wait this is what i was expecting
you
you changed
and so i think that
that's
kind of similar but what you were saying
like the conversation and or what pearl
was saying how he says hey you've gained
some weight i would respect that and if
i didn't if yeah i took it and i was
like you know what i'm not getting no
way i'm just a little tired
and
i gained more weight more weight and i
was not
like yeah not smart about it or just
um naive about it and he was like you
know what i told you and you didn't take
the steps to change so is it with
anything i would respect it too to be
honest i mean i think like after you
have a kid like like give me a couple
months after the kids
like more than a couple months
but like
i don't know i feel like i see a lot of
girls like the second they get a ring
just like let themselves like they gain
so much weight
and i'm like
yeah even even in a relationship because
they feel like they've got what they
want yeah but i feel like also men
encourage that as well like there are a
lot of men yeah that's true this is not
even exciting because they don't want
their woman being attracted to other men
they don't want their women to be it's
an eager thing
they will want their women to
sorry they don't want a woman being
attractive to other men but the other
the other but do those same men get
angry about those women gaining weight
no like because they like it they've
encouraged english yeah they want you to
be
they want you to be unattractive to
other people but then where is the like
you know where's the balance
where's the best
there's also men that lie to women and
say like that like they're attracted to
their wife when they're really not
anymore and they're not like how many
guys do you think really have the balls
when they're girls gaining weight that
they love to like say that depending on
i was that guy really you said that to a
girl i was that guy if when
my partner was gaining weight i said
listen
babe
you're getting a little weight
do you know what i mean
like i was the devil
really yeah like
i was lying but the thing is let me make
that but but let me but let me tell you
something right
women
lie to other women they lie to their
friends and so when
go on
no this happened someone on our team
i was sad lookit i would i said i was
trying to lose 20 pounds you don't need
to lose 20 pounds i'm like look i used
to be 20 pounds lighter i was hotter
than you weren't hotter than why i'm
like i know i was like
why do we lie i think it's because like
we just you know we want each other to
feel good yeah and everything is hard
stop lying to your friends like
stop lying to your friend let her go let
her go
let her
go um
i think especially when you
don't know them that well
and
that's when it's hard to be more
truthful
and so you know like obviously i'm
getting telling you a little more i
think i can be a little much it was here
but like i also haven't known you like
from yeah or from your future you know
but
um i think from what she was trying to
do is just you know make you feel good
also we're a little drunk
you know a lot of things are coming into
play oh i get it i i think it's like we
have
a natural like inclination to not hurt
each other's feelings for sure and which
brings me on the lines because guys guys
will see that guy and be like bro like
your lips [ __ ] dry bro
like get some [ __ ] like no i'm saying
nobody like get some [ __ ] comics or
some [ __ ]
like
we're okay with that but if a woman says
that to another woman mm-hmm it's like
the world
when it comes to
like we're talking about weight when it
comes to weight and women or just
certain things in women
if you talk about it in a negative way
or if you say like hey like
you're getting you're looking a little
chubby there you go you're jealous
you're just jealous you're just jealous
oh my gosh because it's been like
it's like
when it comes to that there's there
hasn't
been a way to like that's been expressed
right to teach us hey it's okay to
out of a loving way tell your friend
that they are doing something wrong
that's when
that's why
i say that
when women cheat they ain't gonna say
nothing cause it's like oh they're not
gonna be like girl like you cheating on
him
and they're gonna be like go ahead girl
exactly
and
you can do better than him anyway girl
yeah
said that to your partner and she got
upset
that goes back to what i was saying
earlier how you
accountability in yourself and taking
what how that person says it
and how you how you take it and so
people say they want people to be honest
right
but when they are honest they can't take
the honesty
and the thing is as a as men we don't
understand that it's like because we're
honest with our friends and
like we speak honestly yeah when it
comes to a woman it's like
when you go back to
do women want a man that wants to lie
they say oh men are liars
they're lies because they're lying
they're lying because they want to
[ __ ] keep you cool
because you can't take the [ __ ] truth
yo
like we lied to you because you can't
take the truth or do men also also not
give women the opportunity to take that
truth so you're not thinking
you said men like men don't men don't
tell the truth because women can't take
it right am i wrong a lot of women can't
take it okay not all but a lot of women
okay i'm going to talk about exceptions
yeah there are actually a lot of women
that can take the truth but men are a
lot of men are coward and that's just
facts i agree with that that's a lot of
facts but you have to understand that
but i understand that men yeah
men essentially are very biological
biological creatures
so
they're thinking about at the end of the
day getting sex from you mm-hmm at the
end of the day they're thinking about
getting sick
so they're thinking what can i say or do
to still get sex
and if they know that if they need to
keep you happy and not and lie to you to
get sex
a lot of men will do it but a lot of men
can get sex elsewhere but the reason why
just me personally the reason why people
say that me personally i'm quote
controversial
i'm not gonna lie to you i'm like yo
i don't care if about getting sex from
you i'ma tell you the truth ah but the
thing is the last 10 guys have lied to
you
the last 10 guys have lied to you
because they wanted to get sex from you
yeah do you understand so when you come
across me
it's like
oh
oh my god this guy he's a misogynist
it's like no the last 10 guys told you
what they wanted to tell you because
they wanted to get in your panties my
dear
i'm not going to tell you that because i
want to i might want to get your panties
but i don't care but i'm still going to
want to tell you the truth
and whatever happens after that happens
after that do you know what i mean yeah
and you know what it's like and it's
funny
after you told him to choose well and
it's funny because i feel like men would
probably have more success with women if
they were more honest because because we
don't respect it we can tell if you're
just gassing us up that's what it is
especially right well that's why
nowadays um like if a guy is into you so
soon and he's like all in like right
away we don't we're like why we're like
what's going on here
hold the [ __ ] up
what's going on where are you putting an
effort into conversation yeah but i
think it's women generally like we were
talking like women generally they don't
even want it
generally
they want a guy who's got options
i know that's why they don't want a guy
who ain't got no women
you don't think so no no i i'm i'm
saying for me personally yeah um i mean
i want an attractive dude see what
you're an attractive dude will come with
women that if you if you think a guy is
attracted there are other women right
no there are other there are there are
other women that think that you want you
want because i want women to look at my
man
exactly
right yeah yes yes you don't you want a
guy that no one else wants no no
you don't want no regular old dude
that's attractive yeah he explained to
me yeah
you don't women generally don't want a
guy who's not attractive to other women
they want a guy who was attracted to
other women but they feel like they got
it yeah
they